this morning a Washington Post
investigation focuses on Russian
government interference in our election
in August the CIA gave then President
Obama a report quote drawn from sourcing
deep inside the Russian government it
detailed Russian President Vladimir
Putin's direct involvement in a cyber
campaign to disrupt and discredit the
u.s. presidential race national security
correspondent Greg Miller co-wrote The
Washington Post article good morning
good morning Greg first of all to your
team it's incredible read and great
reporting I know you spoke with dozens
of officials why do you call this the
crime of the century and what was in
that report that was given to President
Obama I mean I we called in political
terms the crime of the century because I
think it was an unprecedented assault on
a very fundamental mechanism of American
democracy the way we elect our president
and it was largely to a large degree
successful I mean I'm not saying that it
determined the outcome but we're
certainly still living with the
instability and the uncertainty that
this helped create about our electoral
process and we thought it was really
important to spend a good amount of
reporting time and energy trying to
understand the magnitude of this and why
the Obama administration handled it the
way that it did
Greggy if it was that monumental why did
not the administration at the time do
more in response well that's that
question is at the heart of this story
and that's one of the questions that we
set out to try to answer and there as
you might expect there are several
answers there are some sort of basic
tactical answers the White House was
very concerned that if it acted before
the election Putin might just escalate
it might just provoke even more cyber
activity by Russia things could get a
lot worse was there worried and then
there was a political layer to their
concerns they really were consumed with
worry that if they acted if the Obama
administration acted they would be
accused of using intelligence of using
national security as an issue to try to
help Hillary Clinton and they tried to
avoid that and as we say in the story
you know in a weird way that ends up
boomeranging on them that ends up
meaning that politics did play a major
role in
was a serious factor in their decisions
on how and whether to respond to Russia
and and Greg you're reporting show that
this went directly to President Putin in
the past he had said well if it was a
Russian person that he was a patriot he
is repeatedly denied that he was
directly involved in this your
investigation has shown otherwise right
right I mean that's one of the main
revelations in our story and it's at the
very top of the story the CIA had
blockbuster intelligence at the very
beginning of August last year of
catching Putin's own instructions on
this operation and its objective helped
elect Trump Greg Udall so detail regret
by a number of Obama administration
officials about perhaps their failure to
respond what did you learn I think that
that was fairly widespread among many of
the Obama administration officials we
talked to not all of them of course
those close to the president really
protect his legacy and really defend
what they did in the decisions that they
made but we spoke with many people who
look back on this period with a sense of
remorse and regret and sort of can't
understand themselves why why that
administration couldn't muster couldn't
find a way to do more yeah I mean you
detail in fact even the Secretary of
State John Kerry giving an action memo
that included a package of retaliatory
measures and it was the response from
the White House yet to me that's one of
the more interesting sort of moments in
this in this story that we're telling
Kerry before the election the White
House has decided it's not going to do
anything punitive toward Russia before
the election but Kerry comes right at
the last minute says fine
let's do something right afterward then
we have to we have to respond some way
and we should do it right after the
votes are counted he's basically told no
we're not listening to that right now I
mean it just spoked speaks to the deep
reluctance to take this on but Greg can
you explain why this is so important
because I saw an interview the other day
with a voter who said listen I'm sick of
hearing about this Russian investigation
there's nothing there it didn't change
though they do not tamper with the votes
could you really break down briefly why
this matters I think it matters for many
many reasons
one of them is that US intelligence
agencies have already warned this is
going to happen
and again the US hasn't really figured
out how to safeguard its electoral
process from further interference by
Russia and I mean whether this affected
the outcome whether we have president
Trump as a result of this operation we
may never get an answer to that question
but the instability that we're living
with in Washington right now and the
doubt
that many Americans have about the
security surrounding our basic sort of
fundamental mechanisms of democracy was
an primary Russian objective and one
that they must feel that they
accomplished all right Greg Miller thank
you very much we also echo Nora's
compliment to you great reporting thank
you so much so much thank you